it's time for roses and Rose day with me
you guys so if you've not been here in
which case where have you been we are
recapping Emily Maynard season of The
Bachelorette so that we can catch up on
who Ari is who's the gazzarri well we're
really getting to know him and I've been
doing it with special guests but today
there's no special guests
why because I'm tired because I wasn't
able to book anyone because I forgot to
book someone because I love myself I'm
going to do a terrific show today and
I'm going to help people these are all
reasons are any of them the right wine
anyway so we are on episode of floor why
did I do this why did I do it a 1 am I
having a stroke
we're on episode 4 of The Bachelorette
if you're watching along with us which
you should be because this is getting
good
I think it helps that they got the gout
of Charleston no offense to Charleston
but it already seemed like we were
running out of things to do they're kind
of like yeah now two minutes in there on
a world wide trip beginning in Bermuda
wonderful I love visually something in
the brain I guess anyway but I love
doing the bachelor bachelor I goes to
places like this is everyone's like I
just love it here I could totally see
myself here
yeah it's in Bermuda anyone can everyone
loves it we all want to be in Bermuda
and thank you to the show for taking us
there our suite is breathtaking who the
kids Alejandro I don't know whatever
he's there now you know about the dates
but where are they gonna take place well
this week's would be a little different
also I'm still grappling with how much
explaining Chris used to do on the show
I'd forgotten
he explains he's like here's how a
two-on-one date works in case anyone
didn't know and Doug's like wait if I
don't get a rose I go home
dun dun dun
if there's one given thing to know about
this franchise it's that if you don't
have a rose you are out of Bermuda okay
get it together
so nervous for his date and it's super
easy to push Doug's buttons Doug and I
kind of got into a gazzarri was messing
with him I was on our east side Doug I
mean you keep saying how mature you are
and they go like a father and everything
why are you letting this guys jokes bug
yeah and then you told Emily about it
Oh No thank you Doug mm-hmm Doug annoyed
you know I had just scolded all the boys
[Music]
the word scold it
no one ever use it there's nothing sexy
about it I don't know if anyone other
than your grandmother should say scolded
Doug you keep talking about how old you
are where you're showing your skin age
don't use that word it's a no for me so
then we get to the man of our lives of
our futures of our 20:18 of our new year
our new beginnings re re I am really
growing to love you guys I really really
am are you when I kiss Emily everything
else disappears tell me tell me if you
are because re oh wait what did I write
down Oh Doug and Emily are welcome back
to re sorry I'm wet anyway I'm having a
lot of fun with Doug but I feel like
there's something that he's hiding from
me
Donegan Emily are like both trying to
tell each other about their flaws and
neither one of them can come up with any
flaws Doug's like to see him at me for
like not washing your car not
my last girlfriend didn't like that
didn't wash her car sometimes and
Emily's like I go out of the house in my
pajamas
there's some news I don't get out of my
pajamas sign me up is this that hard
she's like I shouldn't put dog on the
spot with coming up with flaws if
someone said to me right now what are
your flaws I am too critical on myself I
should be nicer to my mom I have
insecurities majorly I talk about my own
weight too much I shouldn't weigh myself
every day Wow a lot of my flaws are
about weight and body confidence I mean
I could just I could go the on you guys
okay but they're like sometimes I don't
put on regular clothes I say my didn't
go out in public and run my everyday
errand wow this is your list of flaws so
then they do like a sailing race on the
group date which cool right man I've
always wanted to be in a sailboat I've
seen a very cinematic way I'm
considering getting a sailboat for my
birthday and kind of boating around and
sipping Chardonnay or rose' both really
and wearing sweater and pretending a
minute Nancy Meyers movie if anybody
wants to come I need friends so one team
the red team loses the sailing race and
all I have to say about this is that a
guy was crying in the van about this I
don't know who he was but don't cry over
losing the sailing race sir
anyway so then we get into Ryan it's a
good thing Emily is a solid Bachelorette
who's not messing around with this
garbage because she's got a few weirdos
in this bunch whew Ryan toasts to Emily
being a trophy wife possible it's a note
for me Ryan and Arie called him out on
that yes Ari Ari's like the things Ryan
says are not okay and you know what I
want to applaud Ari for being ahead of
his time five years later we are trying
to get men to call out other men and say
that's not okay and Ari did it Ari from
bachelor 20/80 no way he is
something is right in the world anyway I
really don't know what anything guys
like I still love Peter Peter
I still love Peter and he's gonna be on
winter games so nobody's gonna worry but
I'm getting excited about all right yeah
so are each team one so he gets some
time with Emily and they meet on a beach
to talk and him and Emily are sharing
what I would call the most distracting
blanket I've ever seen in my life who
approved that blanket for on camera
there's so many tassels I can't stop
staring at it I mean he is shining in
the moonlight once again I can't figure
out why no one was blotting the oil off
of these people's faces in this season
but he's shining and it's Ari's time to
shine in 2018 you guys I can't wait
then it's Jeff's turn sloppy seconds on
the blanket for Jeff the blanket returns
the blanket gets more screen time than
some of these guys Jeff's voice is
unsettling to me I don't know I really
like who you are like I'm like I don't
know like it's weird and some of the
things he said were weird he says quote
I hurt my fingers for you Oh which means
like just thing to say in this weird
moment you I wrote down you it will it
will how did this guy win you think
about it I don't know drink when he
don't know back to Ryan so Ryan shows
his true colors
if the color of this show is red like a
rose and the color of Ryan is black like
a skin heart okay here's what we find
out Ryan says something like she's the
Bachelorette I want to see her do a lot
with it I had a lot of coaches tell me
the enemy of great it's good does that
mean and then we find out that Ryan
wants to be the bachelor he's literally
saying out loud as if unaware that he's
miked but he like wants to be bachelor
and he's gonna like use this for media
and you know as we know now that it's
2017 Ryan did not become the bachelor
rightfully so some of the things that
come out here and ask them like where in
the world does that come from uncouth
and Jeff gets the group-date rose and
Jeff is shocked and so are we
because why didn't I get it I don't know
maybe I think Emily has like that
instant attraction to Jeff you know and
so she's like she's giving that to him
but it's like yeah she wants more he's
anyway Ryan is definitely overly
confident he seems to feel like they had
the strong connection Ari again calls
Ryan out says he thinks he's a
narcissist yes yes yes Ari is right ryan
tells Emily she should show him her
worth it's it shows how far we've come
none of these comments are okay none of
them are okay oh I love this tell me
what you really think about me I want to
know this is interesting you know I want
to know she says in the most adorable
southern girl way possible when she's
sitting on the porch all right pops into
her mind that is so sweet
what do you want to hear someone say
about you other than that when you're
not around they think about you that is
so sweet
and Ari loves it and I don't I feel like
they wouldn't like let someone say in
the past that like oh you're the one I'm
thinking about Jeff I don't know I get
to keep watching yeah I know there are
some serious feelings on the line but
that just makes the decision she has to
make here tonight that much tougher and
some guys we don't remember go home
[Music]
we live for another episode that's that
you guys I really am I'm falling more in
love with re with each app which is
amazing because that should happen and
this gave me very excited for the new
season which premieres in January on a/c
so you guys are you watching with me
what do you think of re and are you
getting more excited around it in
bachelor let me know over on social
medias I'm on Twitter and on Instagram
I've been a little bit over snapchat
lately but anyway make sure to like it
see on Facebook subscribe to us on
YouTube and tune in to roses and Rosie
because we will be having more guests in
the future exciting people I was just
obsessed with myself today
kind of like Ryan and I think we're
gonna be doing some double-size episodes
coming up thank you so much for watching
I love you so much
I love you as much as I love Rosie mmm
truth be told this rose day is a week
old but I'm not sure if at this point
it's juice or wine but I'm gonna go with
wine because I'm feeling the effects
everybody love you much
[Applause]
my birthday's coming up you guys I don't
know how to feel about it downward
spiral or pure celebration it's a choice
I have to make for myself Wow